this right here is a solid or ever solid
of revolution whose volume we were able
to figure out in previous videos
actually in a different tutorial using
the disk method and integrating in terms
of why we're going to do it now is we're
going to find the same volume for the
same solid of revolution but we're going
to do it using the shell method and
integrating with respect to X so what we
do is we have the region between these
two curves Y is equal to square root of
x and y is equal to x squared and we're
going to rotate it around the vertical
line x equals two and we're going to do
that and at the interval that we're
going to rotate this space between these
two curves is the interval between when
square root of x is greater than x
squared and so it's between zero and one
and so let's try to do it with the shell
method and so to do that what we do is
we want to construct a shell so let's
imagine
let me just in a different color let's
imagine a rectangle right over here
let's imagine a rectangle right over
there it has width DX so it has width DX
and its height is the difference of
these two functions and so if I were to
draw it right over here it would look
something like this
so it would look something like that so
it'd be there it'd be there and then it
is a shell it's kind of a hollowed-out
cylinder so it would look something
something like this it would look
something like that
just like that and it has some depth
that's what the DX gives us so we have
the depth that looks something like that
and then let me shade it in a little bit
just so we can see a little bit of its
see a little bit of its depth so when
you rotate this rectangle around the
line x equals two you get a shell like
this so let's think about how we can
figure out the volume of this shell well
we've already done this several times
the first thing we might want to think
about is the circumference of kind of
the top of the shell the circumference
of the top of the shell we know
circumference is 2 pi times radius we
just need to know what the radius of the
shell is what is this distance what is
that distance going to be well it's the
horizontal distance between X
equals two and whatever the x-value is
right over here so it's going to be it's
going to be two minus our x-values so
this radius this distance right over
here is going to be two minus X and so
the circumference is going to be that
times two pi two pi R gives us the
circumference of that circle so 2 pi
times two minus X and then if we want
the surface area of the outside of our
shell so the area is going to be the
circumference 2 pi times 2 minus x times
the height of each shell now what is the
height of each shell well it's going to
be the distance between it's going to be
the vertical distance expressed as
functions of Y so it's going to be the
top boundary is y is equal to square
root of x the bottom boundary is y is
equal to x squared so it's going to be
square root of x minus x squared so let
me make this so it's going to be it's
going to be let me do this in the yellow
so it's going to be square root of x
minus minus x squared and so if you want
the volume of a given shell it's going
to be and I'll write all of this in
white it's going to be 2 pi times 2
minus x times square root of x minus x
squared so this whole expression we just
I just rewrote it is the SIRT is e is
the area the outside surface area of one
of these shells if we want the volume we
have to give it a little bit of depth
multiplied by how deep the shell is so
times DX and if we want the volume of
this whole thing we just have to sum up
all the shells for all of the X's in
this interval and take the limit as the
DX is gets smaller and smaller and we
have more and more shells and so what's
our interval
well our X's are going to go between 0 &
1 0 & 1 so that right over there is the
volume of this is the volume of this
figure